les français qui le souhaitent vacciner
à l'été 2000 21 aider à vacciner les
pays les plus pauvres en leur
fournissant des doses
telles sont les intentions partagé par
emmanuel macron ce mardi soir lors d'une
prise de parole en direct
il promet aussi une accélération de la
production
aujourd'hui ce qui nous contraint c'est
l'accès aux doses est donc ce qu'il faut
réussir à mobiliser ce sont tous les
laboratoires qui permettent de produire
ces vaccins homologués par nos autorités
sanitaires pour le plus vite possible
acquérir le maximum de doses en toute
sécurité
et pour cela le gouvernement a identifié
quatre sites sur le sol français
capables de produire des doses de vaccin
en eure-et-loir delpharm produira le
vaccin de pfizer bio andtek en
indre-et-loire récit farm produire à
celui de modern à dans le val-de-marne
où sanofi produira un vaccin quand il
sera disponible dans l'eure et à pau
fareva aidera à la production du vaccin
allemand curve ac
bien qu'il ne soit pas encore homologué
un projet qui devrait débuter d'ici la
fin du mois mais ces laboratoires
pharmaceutiques ne produiront pas
l'intégralité des doses en raison de
contraintes liées à la propriété
intellectuelle
à ce stade ce sera effectivement du
flaconnage mais il est important de
garder à l'esprit qu'il s'agit d'une
opération très complexe notamment pour
les vaccins arn messager dont les
molécules sont très fragiles on ne
s'improvise pas flac honneur emmanuel
macron a également évoqué la mission
scientifique en voyant en russie pour
découvrir le vaccin spoutnik v des
échanges positifs selon le chef de
l'état qui dit attendre la demande
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché du
producteur russe envers les autorités
européennes